في التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قتل شخص واصيب 16 بجروح في قصف
روسي على مقاطعه خرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا
خلال الساعات ال 24 الاخيره وقالت الاداره
العسكريه للاقليم ان القوات الروسيه نفذت
100 هجوم واطلقت نحو 700 قذيفه في الاثناء
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته حققت
انجازا جزئيا في الهجوم المضاد الذي
يتواصل على محوري زابروجيا
وبخمس وذكر الجيش ان قواته تصدت لهجمات
روسيه في منطقه ماكيفك بمنطقه لوغانسك وفي
منطقه دونيتسك تصدت القوات الاوكرانيه
لهجمات روسيه في بلدتي اديكا وشاختار سكي
من جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
انظمه دفاعاتها الجويه دمرت الليله
الماضيه 31 مسيره اوكرانيه فوق اراضي
مناطق بجرود وبريان سك وكورس كما احبطت
محاوله انزال اوكرانيه باستخدام قارب سريع
ودراجات مائيه سريعه غربيه شبه جزيره
القرم قال جهاز الامن المركزي الاوكراني
انه استهدف مجمعا لمنصات الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه من طراز اس 400 في مقاطعه بجرود
الروسيه دون ان يوضح طريقه الاستهداف
لمزيد من الاضاءه الميدانيه معنا من
زبروجيا مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس نعم بالفعل ونبدا ربما من هذا
الاعلان الذي جاء من جهاز الامن المركزي
المعروف باس بي يو في اوكرانيا الذي اشار
فيه الى ان ال الجهاز نجح في تسديد ضربه
لمنظومه الصواريخ اس 400 في بجرود وهو
يقول بان هذا هذه ليست الضربه الاولى انما
الضربه الثانيه التي تاتي في اقل من شهر
بعد ان كان استهدف منظومه مماثله في بوريا
في شبه جزيره القرم وذا الاستهداف الذي
كان في القرم ربما هو ما مكن سلاح الجو
الاوكراني من توجيه الضربات الى مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود اهميه هذه الضربات التي توجه
لمنظومه اس 400 تحديدا في منطقه اي شبه
جزيره القرم هي ترتبط ايضا بالعمليات
العسكريه المتواصله على محور زبروجيا
جنوبا ذلك ان القوات الاوكرانيه تسعى الى
توجيه ضربات الى القواعد العسكريه الروسيه
تحديدا في شبه جزيره القرم الى المطارات
التي تستخدم في ضرب العمق الاوكراني
وتحديدا في منطقه العمليات ونفي زبروجيا
وايضا قطع او محاوله قطع الامدادات
العسكريه الروسيه التي تاتي من شبه جزيره
القرم لمسانده القوات العامله على محور
زبروجيا لكن اللافت اليوم وبعد ان اي كان
الجيش الاوكراني منذ اكثر من شهر اعلن عن
انه نجح في اختراق خط الدفاع ال الاول
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه في منطقه زبروجيا
اليوم لاول مره ربما يعلن الجيش الاوكراني
بانه احرز ولو تقدما جزئيا في منطقه بفيفي
تحديدا في جهتها الغربيه لم يشر الى طبيعه
هذا التقدم لكن واضح بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعثرت في هذا المحور لكثير من
الوقت لاكثر من شهر وما يزيد وهي تقول
بانها احرزت الان تقدما في الجهه الغربيه
لبفف والوجهه بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
على هذا المحور تحديدا هي بلده توكك هذه
البلده التي يقول الجيش الاوكراني بانه
اذا دخلها او سيطر عليها فانه سيتقدم
ويندفع سريح سريعا نحو الهدف الرئيسي لهذه
العمليه وهو مدينه ملتبل من الواضح ايضا
بان القوات الروسيه تتخذ اجراءات على
الارض في محاوله لمنع انهيارات انهيار
دفاعاتها في تلك المنطقه الجيش الاوكراني
كان كشف عن امر هام في الايام الاخيره وهو
ان القوات الروسيه تقوم بشق طريق سريع
جديد بعيدا عن المناطق المدنيه والمناطق
الماهوله من ماريوبل حتى منطقه ملتبل وهذا
يعزيه البعض الى ان القوات الروسيه ربما
تتخوف من انهيارات في جبهتها في منطقه
زبرو جنوبا او احتمال ان تتمكن القوات
الاوكرانيه من السيطره على الخط السريع
الواصل بين فولنا فاخ وتب ولذلك تسعى الى
ايجاد ربما بدائل لامدادات عبر انشاء هذا
الشارع الجديد ياسك منجيا شكرا جزيلا لك